I am pretty ruthless when it comes to
the people that I have in my life I tend
to have a relatively contrarian view on
relationships which is that I do believe
that all relationships are transactional
if you never got anything positive at
some point most humans will cease to
continue the relationship and so if we
think about human behavior in terms of
reinforcers and punishers because those
are the only two things that sticks and
carrots right the people that we've had
a longer period of time with we are
willing to wait a longer period of time
before we are reinforced to continue to
spend time with them so we will wait
longer periods of time before we get
another carrot which then kicks it out
again right for the next carrot to come
when I look at the relationships that I
have I try to cut off the back side I
don't want to keep a relationship
because I have always had it but only
insofar as it will continue to add value
and more so that it is aligned with
where I want to go